bonsoir
Alain nous sommes de retour sur Terre
toujours en compagnie de Mazarine
Pingeot
je veux un réveil et le 15 0
0 € bonsoir
plus Benoît 16 - Rocky 4 ça fait combien
quelqu'un en 12
12 absolument
un événement
que vous attendez depuis plus d'un an
ici parce que ça y est c'est officiel on
ne parle plus de frigide Barjot
[Applaudissements]
quel bon moment c'est fini mais non il a
ressorti un livre ah merde
c'est
la sortie de votre livre
que sont-elles devenues un livre
d'enquête sur plusieurs grandes affaires
de disparition non résolue alors là
c'est le 15 0 enquêteur
[Musique]
alors c'est un livre d'enquête sur
plusieurs grandes affaires de
disparition non résolue la petite m'a
dit Estelle Mouzin les disparues de
Perpignan Jeanne Mas
Salut sérieux
alors commençant par m'a dit donc enlevé
au Portugal il y a 7 ans le mystère
demeure total jusqu'à aujourd'hui alors
à disparaître ses parents dîner dans un
restaurant en face de la chambre où elle
était couchée et pendant le dîner et ses
parents sont souvent aller dans la
chambre et la dernière visite la petite
est plus là alors qu'il y a encore les
deux jumeaux alors pour la police
portugaise m'a dit est morte dans sa
chambre et les parents ont maquillé la
mort accidentelle en enlèvement oui il
aurait donné alors qu'ils sont médecin
tous les deux c'est pas très plausible
il aurait donné trop de calmants et elle
serait morte et ensuite il dort est
caché sous le canapé où Dieu c'est où
dans la voiture dans le coffre de la
voiture puis je serais allé s'en
débarrasser ça tient pas une minute pour
vous la piste la plus crédible dans
cette affaire c'est celle des réseaux
pédophiles
vous supposez que ma vie a été enlevée
conduite sur un bateau par des passeurs
et vous dis que c'est un bus qui
rapporte plus que la drogue oui je te
dire que bon à chaque fois qu'on parle
de ça on nous dit c'est un fantasme que
ce soit gendarme policier que c'est un
fantasme dans l'histoire de m'a dit ça
ressemble plus à une commande puisque il
y a des guetteurs la police anglaise
maudit maintenant il y avait 2 personnes
de type blondes ont qu'ils disent
peut-être il était allemand peut-être
des Pays-Bas et ils sont restés une
semaine quand même autour de l'hôtel à
regarder et ensuite une famille
d'Irlandais va croiser un monsieur qui
dirige vers le port avec une petite
fille blonde avec le même pyjama une
couverture demain la ressemble un peu à
voilà à la commande d'autant qu'il y a
un pédophile du coin après date heure
qui est arrêté et qui dit ah oui ça
arrive souvent
bon parfois c'est pour nous et parfois
c'est des livraisons
autre affaire Estelle Mouzin et la piste
des parents il y a la piste du resto
chinois ils ont démonté un restaurant
chinois entièrement soi-disant pour
retrouver les ossements de la petite
j'ai même pas démonter ils ont défoncé à
la pelleteuse ça a coûté finalement
300000 € à l'état de rembourser les pour
chinois tu saches que des ouvriers vu
des ossements en construisant resto
c'était des ossements de poulet le chien
en fait là aussi supposer que ce sont
des des réseaux pédophiles
liés aux fichiers de chambre c'est
quelque chose qui va apparaître en 1999
suite à l'enquête d'un monsieur qui
s'appelle vers Lausanne qui est un Belge
qui va remonter tout tout un réseau
comme ça pédophile et aboutir à ce
fichier que lui confie un dégât du
réseau donc ce sont des photos des
vidéos il y a 12 CD Rom il y a des
images seulement indescriptible donc
c'est c'est c'est des Roms vont être mis
à la justice belge néerlandaise et
française
équivalent de rien en faire l'affaire
est sorti à l'époque par un journaliste
de l'humanité qui s'appelle Serge garder
ce monsieur reçois des tas d'appel de
parents qui ont vu leurs enfants
disparaître et qui donc demande à voir
ses fichiers la police veux pas rentrer
donc ils viennent à l'humanité voir les
fichiers et 80 d'entre eux vont
reconnaître leurs enfants et aller voir
la police et ça se soldera par le fait
que la police leur dire ah non il s'agit
de 80 sosies
donc c'est quand même et vous Rif
pourquoi les flics
dirai ce sont des sosies c'est quoi
l'intérêt
pose la question
en fait
mais ce que je veux dire ce bébé il
existait pas un fantasme c'est c'est un
truc qui existe alors c'est qui ce bébé
c'est un sosie mais de qui ça c'est pas
sérieux ou quoi
comment changer les idées on va jouer à
un quiz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors les réponses commencent par Z
d'accord un monument de la télévision
qui ne soit pas
[Applaudissements]
un truc à rayures qui ne soit pas kazero
bon
tu as un truc que les femmes aiment bien
qu'il ne soit pas car zéro
il y avait le zgeg
zibeline à l'ancienne un truc
dégueulasse qui ne soit pas
[Applaudissements]
non parce que c'est vraiment dégueulasse
votre métaphore c'est une pratique
sexuelle qui ne soit pas cassé
une célébrité qui ne soit pas kazero Z
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
YouTube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu